Hey Youtubers It's Charlie is a new Star Wars
trailer coming they posted a quick teaser,
so this is going to be a breakdown of this
as well as the poster there a couple of new
things on the poster that we haven't seen
yet the biggest thing about this new footage
is that we see Finn in rebel gear really the
two options here are that pin starts out as
a rebel or he starts out with the Empire and
becomes a rebel you can kind of see one of
the black explains here that he is walking
by Daisy really poor still educated that's
the planet where she and Finn meet up you
actually if you play the Star Wars game though
the battlefront game the releasing this holiday
season you will be able to see that they have
some special DLC called the battle of Jakku
so it takes place like right before Star Wars
episode seven picks up the super weapon up
here in the upper right-hand corner of this
poster lost the Empire looks a lot like the
death Star probably somewhere near the Starkiller
base if you member the Starkiller base was
named just in honor of Luke's Starkiller the
you know the original name for Luke Skywalker
and George Lucas's first script the actual
base is on the ice planet we've seen the surface
of that without a drivers character in these
these promos here and we've seen the inside
of it in the last trailer as promo obviously
has a lot of stuff to you seen before we see
Capt.
fast was character we see the first-order
storm troopers and if you look in the background
here it looks like we're seeing Maz Canata
for the first time Lupita's character she's
doing a motion capture rolled just like Andy
circuses now Andy circuses playing supreme
leader's note probably not can it be in any
event marketing materials to be like putting
the Emperor on the first original Star Wars
poster the other really big thing we have
to talk about is the lack of Luke Skywalker
that they were kind of open about this several
months ago where they were like we know were
not going to be putting Luke Skywalker in
any of our marketing materials he will carry
over to episode a theater there is a rumor
that some original trilogy member or at least
one of them could die but I think the likely
candidate would be Han Solo because Harrison
Ford really only gets excited for interesting
stories and he said like a long time ago when
they were shooting return of the Jedi he really
wanted George Lucas to kill Han Solo in that
third movie that of course George Lucas being
a enterprising businessman was like I'm not
gonna kill one of my most popular characters
living now they're trying to transition to
the new cast the the producers of Star Wars
Kathleen Kennedy all those people will be
much more open to killing off Han Solo given
the he is an old man now he probably wouldn't
be long for the Galaxy anyway let me know
what you guys think of the poster was happening
next this is there to be posting a full trailer
during ESPN's Monday Night Football I know
that sounds but I'll explain why in the second
will totally be doing a video for anima to
be giving away my reverse flash ring from
my flash arrow Q&A's of you but if you been
following like the flash giveaways just just
because so much happened and I was able to
do that video on the giveaway the ring in
the Star Wars trailer video I think is pretty
reasonable to assume that everybody that watches
my flash videos to watch that Star Wars trailer
video but more camels speaking of some common
ground Mark Campbell will be back for the
flash season two so if you like his trickster
character from season one will totally be
back but just explain why there posting a
new Star Wars trailer during Monday Night
Football of all places is because the ratings
are so high they want people to see the trailer
and go see the movie that normally wouldn't
be trolling the Internet for that kind of
footage thing about it this way you guys that
are watching this and meet were huge Star
Wars fan so of course were going to like have
our ear to the ground for any kind of new
footage new images stuff like that but there
are a lot of people that just have no awareness
for that that's what Monday Night Football
is for advance ticket sales are also going
to open Monday if you want to make sure that
you don't get shut out on the 18th whenever
the movie comes out your like you want to
buy your ticket right now you can do that
on Monday night if you have an IMAX theater
somewhere near where you live I would advise
that you see it in IMAX because they did use
an IMAX camera for a bunch of very special
sequences or he gets only do like me and you
can go see like a regular theater and see
it in IMAX there are a whole lot of movies
that I would go see more than once but Star
Wars is definitely one of those franchises
shut up and take my money so everybody look
out there's gonna be a walking dead video
later tonight but then that Star Wars trailer
will post on Monday night so get hype just
in case you guys haven't seen it there been
a bunch of other Star Wars clips and trailers
that I posted you can click here to watch
all those and you can click here for the game
of thrones video that I just posted all about
Ashara Dayne thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five and I'll see you guys tonight!